So last time we talked a little bit
about the state of the world of belief,
I suppose by the end of the 19th century
and I talked to you a little bit about
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky and and
character guard.
I'm a very large number of the clinical
theories that we're going to be
discussing for another two lectures
after this one have been influenced by
philosophers.
And that's partly why I'm also talking
to you about the philosophers.
It's almost as if in some sense the
great philosophers have our tap directly
into the lower strata of our,
our,
our cultural systems of meaning as they
move forward in time and they can
outline what those structures are and
also describe their weaknesses and their
strengths and their likely
transformation moving forward.
You know,
I mean obviously people can be behind
the times and just as it's just as
probable that some people are ahead of
the times and we would assume,
if you're thinking about it to say from
a big five traits perspective,
that the people who are ahead of the
times often are very,
very intelligent and very,
very open.
And of course that's a pretty good
definition of a philosopher,
so Nietzsche and Dostoevsky,
I think more than any other two thinkers
had their finger on the pulse of the
transmutation of cultural systems,
of meaning in the at the end of the 19th
century,
and they were both very concerned about
the fact that the systems of meaning
within which Western civilization at
least had taken shape,
had been fragmented for a variety of
reasons.
The most important of which was likely
the rise of the scientific world view.
And as I detailed to you in the last
lecture,
both Dostoevsky and Nisha believed that
that had left modern people.
Because I think in the early 20th
century it was Western people,
but now I think it's reasonable to say
that it's modern people in a state of
their.
Their,
their cultural discontinuity things,
belief systems,
but also technological systems now have
transformed the world so radically that
the conflict between modernism and
traditional forms of belief is acutely
felt everywhere.
It certainly,
I think one of the forces that have
given rise to the battle between Islamic
fundamentalism and modernism because
it's more of that than a battle of
Islamic fundamentalism against the
Western world,
and the problem fundamentally is that
people typically exist within cultural
constructs that are very,
very ancient and that have,
that are grounded in in evolved systems
of meaning that it are even deeper than
the ones that are articulated and
explicit and when there's a period of
very,
very rapid cognitive and technological
change than the integrity of those
systems starts to.
It starts to become questionable from an
explicit perspective,
but it also starts to become
insufficient from a practical
perspective.
So one example that you might give some
consideration to is the fact of the
introduction of the birth control pill.
For example,
if you listen to politically minded
people,
they make the case that the emancipation
of women was essentially a political
matter,
but I don't think that that's a very
reasonable way of looking at it at all.
Of course,
the things,
everything feeds back onto itself and
there are multiple causal pathways to
any and the radical element in the
emancipation of women was of course the
development of efficient forms of
contraception,
most particularly the birth control
pill,
and it's the case that as soon as you
educate women anywhere in the world,
not only does economic productivity rise
dramatically,
in fact,
it's actually the best predictor of
increase in economic predict
productivity in a modernizing state is
the granting of rights to women.
Now,
whether it's directly because of the
granting of rights to women or because
of the existence of an underlying belief
structure that allows the concept of
right to expand quite rapidly.
It's very difficult to be sure of,
but in any case that exists,
and then of course the other thing that
happens is that women stop having
children unbelievably rapidly.
So for example,
I think,
I believe it's Iran where this has been
most market over the last two
generations,
so from family size is far greater than
replacement two family sizes well below
replacement in basically one or two
generations.
It's a massive transformation and it's
not necessarily something that anyone
expected.
It's part of the sequence of forces that
are rapidly allowing our population to
reach a peak and then either stabilize
or decline.
I don't know how many of you know this,
but the projections are that there'll be
9 billion people on the earth within 30
to 50 years and that'll be our peak
population after that,
it will fall rapidly and you know,
you can see that sort of thing happening
right now all over the western world and
it's happening a lot in China and it's
happening in Japan where there are more
older people than there are younger
people because the younger people aren't
having enough children to actually
replace the population.
So the probability that will peak at
about $9 million and then start to fall.
It's not certain,
but that's what the best projections
seemed.
Indicate now.
Oh,
so what happens anyways with in periods
of very rapid technological and
cognitive transformation,
because those things go together,
that the certainties upon which people
base their interpretation of the world
and even more importantly base their
judgments about how to act start to
become uncertain.
So for example,
if you introduce the birth control pill
into a population and you put women's
reproductive faculties under their own
voluntary choice,
then you radically transformed virtually
all of society's fundamental social
structures,
not least marriage and marriage of
course,
is being regarded plastically as the
foundation of civilization and of course
increasingly there are more people who
aren't married.
Then there are people who are married
now.
It's very difficult to know what to make
of that because of course there's no
setting the clock back and it's not even
clear that you would want to set back
the clock if you could,
but expecting cultural constructs,
which takes centuries or maybe even
thousands or maybe even tens of
thousands of years to develop,
to keep up with change of that magnitude
is.
It's not possible.
No,
I mean,
and you guys face technological
transformations that are earth
shattering on an almost yearly basis and
you hardly even notice it.
I mean,
tinder is a good example of that.
You know,
I don't know if you know,
but tinder is produced quite a spike in
sexually transmitted diseases,
but you know,
it's a radical technology because it's
the first technology that's ever been
invented that enables men to find
partners with no fear,
with virtually no fear of rejection.
And of course that's been a limiting
factor for.
That's been a defining feature of the
interactions between men and women ever
since history began.
And so these things are occurring at,
at an extraordinary rate and of course
it's not reasonable to expect are more
slower moving cultural constructs to
keep up with them.
And that's partly because as well that
you know,
people talk for example,
about the divisive nature of religion.
You often hear people who are critics of
formal religion in particular talk about
the fact that religion,
underwire underlies a tremendous amount
of destruction and warfare and conflict.
And you know,
first of all,
it isn't religion that does that.
By the way,
it's tribalism and tribalism
characterizes even chimpanzees and I
don't think chimpanzees go to war with
each other for religious reasons.
So you know,
the religious groupings of mankind are
our large scale manifestations of the
same phenomena that produce dominance
hierarchies in the wild and of course
large scale religions unite people
within the religion just as much as they
divide people on the outside of it.
So part of the accumulation of religious
tradition across time is a process that
allows thousands and 10,
thousands and even millions of people to
exist within the same hierarchy of
values and exist relatively peacefully.
As a consequence.
Now I'm saying relatively peacefully,
you know,
a hundred years ago it was thought that
pre,
let's say,
let's say archaic people.
So those would be people who are still
living a fairly isolated tribal life in
small groups,
pre,
you know,
basically operating at the level of
stone age technology.
Let's say the idea was there was a very
popular idea for a long time that those
cultures were,
um,
communistic and violence free.
And that's wrong.
They're not violence for you at all.
If you track the homicide rates in stone
age,
culture is there way,
way higher than they are in civilized
cultures like orders of magnitude
higher.
And there's a variety of reasons for
that,
but I'm just telling you that because
you want to dispense with the idea that
along with complex civilizations and
this friend say of unifying religious
beliefs,
there was an increase,
an increase in baseline violence because
there's just no evidence for that at
all.
Now,
the problem with these large scale
belief systems is they're not very fast.
And part of the reason for that is that
in order for a large scale belief system
and to,
to,
uh,
manifest itself in any reasonable forum,
it has to be predicated on the mutual
agreement of the people within whom
within,
who operate within its embrace.
You know?
So for,
for Toronto to exist as a city,
as a peaceful city,
basically what has to happen is that the
vast majority of us have to agree that
the rules that govern the city and the
social interactions within the city are
useful.
And just.
And because if you don't agree with
that,
then splinter movements of all starts
start to occur and people become more
revolutionary in their modes of action
and then they become more violent and
the whole system starts to break down.
So it's not easy to establish a
collective norm because people have to
agree to it.
And you can imagine that hammering out
agreement with anything,
with even a small agreement that affects
many,
many people is a process that takes a
tremendous amount of time.
People can argue forever about the
smallest alterations in the systems that
regulate our behavior.
Now,
you know,
some of you might be familiar with the
terror management theories.
How many of you have heard of terror
management theory?
Okay,
well,
the terror management theories that are
predicated on the idea that our belief
systems protect us from our fear of
death.
Now exactly how they do that isn't
specified particularly well in the
terror management theories.
But the originator of the theory,
whose name was Ernest Becker,
who was a sociologist by the way and
afraid,
Ian,
um,
believed that cultural systems enabled
us to attribute beliefs to our actions,
finite and infinite,
so that we could consider ourselves in
relationship to mortality.
And in some sense,
hide from the truth of the attitude of
our existence.
Now,
one of the things that terror management
theorists don't really give any credence
to is the fact that belief systems are
not only systems of belief systems of
action regulation,
right?
So we've talked about the pig Eddie and
notion of a game.
The game exists first as something that
everyone can play and only later as
something that people represent and a
social cultures the same way,
a cultural,
a culture regulates the way that you
interact with each other and what you
expect from each other and how you can
fulfill your mutual,
your needs in relationship to one
another.
And then it's represented and the
representation might help you find
meaning in your life.
But the fact of the initial social
contract,
which is the phenomena that regulates
your interpersonal behavior,
doesn't protect you from the fear of
death that protects you from dying.
And,
and that's a very important thing to
note.
I mean,
you know,
all of you know,
of course it's very cold out today and
yet here you are in this classroom where
it's Renault ridiculously comfortable,
you know,
by classroom standards and of course by
standards around the world and you're
not freezing to death in here.
And that's not your belief.
It's protecting you.
It's the fact that you're embedded in
this insanely complicated system of
cultural interactions.
And it just so happens that you get to
sit here and listen to a lecture.
Well,
there's thousands of people being
around.
Many of them outside in the cold,
making sure that the power grid,
for example,
that keeps this place warm,
is property maintained and functional,
which takes a tremendous amount of work.
So when in,
during periods of rapid transformation,
it's hard for the social contract to
adjust itself so that everyone knows how
to behave in relationship to one
another.
But then it's also very difficult for
the description of that.
So the articulated norms that constitute
a society,
it's very difficult for them to
transform rapidly enough so that they
can keep track of the,
of the changes and and help people
decide what they should do.
So let me give you an example.
So I had a client Hawaiian back who had
been raised as the fundamentalist
Christian and she was very.
She had been socialized and had come to
believe that sex before marriage was
wrong,
but the probability that she was going
to get married before she was 27 or 28
was low for a whole variety of reasons.
And so then she faced this conundrum and
it was an interesting conundrum from my
perspective because you know,
I think that in a well regulated psyche,
sexuality is integrated into the
personality so that it's so that it
plays its role in the,
what would you call in the quality of
the self.
It's integrated properly inside.
And so it's under moral control,
roughly speaking because it serves its
own function,
plus the function of,
of keeping the person well situated in
the present and developing property in
the future and maintaining proper
relationships with everyone around them.
But it was quite obvious to me that a
lot of the constraints that had been
placed on her behavior as a consequence
of her relatively rigid belief,
we're actually interfering with her
development as a person,
you know.
And so one of the things we had to
puzzle out was,
well,
exactly what are the moral guidelines
that you should use to regulate your
sexual behavior outside of marriage?
If you're not planning to be married
for,
you know,
maybe until your late twenties.
Well,
you know,
good luck trying to figure that out.
Like it's a really.
It's a really,
really,
really complicated question.
And it's certainly not obvious that any
one person can figure out the answer to
that in a single lifetime.
You know,
even if they thought,
if nothing else,
especially because the landscape itself
is transforming as you're attempting to
adjust to it.
You know,
when we eventually concluded,
although it was a very individual
solution,
we eventually concluded that there were
things that she had forbidden herself to
do,
that we're stopping her from
establishing any kind of longterm
relationship at all and that that was
interfering with her development,
you know,
as a mature person and that the morality
that she had used to structured her
behavior appeared to be
counterproductive.
At least,
you know,
in some,
in some areas.
So it's one thing to,
you know,
to,
to regulate sexuality in the hopes of
marriage when you get married when
you're 19 or 20 or 21,
it's a completely different thing when
it's perhaps not going to happen until
you're in your late twenties.
So now need shit talked a lot and
Dostoevsky talked a lot about the
collapse of meaning systems in the late
19th century.
And you know,
that was followed by a very,
very rapid period.
Technological transformation like that
really kicked in in the late 18
hundreds,
which was the,
you know,
the.
Well was it the height of the industrial
revolution,
particularly in England.
And there were modern technologies being
thrust out of the industrial revolution,
like mad,
like the automobile in the airplane,
in the electric light and recording
devices and all of the things that we're
still elaborating on now.
And then of course,
apart from the collapse of classic,
Say Christian belief and the
introduction of all these new
technologies.
When World War One hit the entire
monarchical structure of the Western
world collapsed.
And that also occurred say with regards
to the Ottoman Empire.
And that was partly what led to the
creation of the modern Middle East.
And of course we're still,
that still hasn't been sorted out to any
great degree at all.
So the monarchical structures collapsed.
These ancient civilizations,
Russians underwent their revolution and
we're,
you know,
and were transformed into communists.
And then after World War One,
the stress between the potential
different ways of structuring societies
after the monarchical societies had
collapsed,
was almost unbearable.
And people didn't really know what to
do.
No.
Okay.
What happened at,
at the end of niches,
period and Dostoyevsky's period?
Was that the question that both of those
people,
what?
No
most important question.
Both of those people asked became the
central focus of the development of
philosophical ideas of ethics in the
20th century,
so you could think about those.
Is that as a kind of a post religious
ethic?
Now the reason I'm telling you this is
because among other things is because a
lot of what cycle analytic or
psychotherapeutic treatment is about is
about ethics and that can't be stressed
too much because ethics is about how you
see the world and how you behave and so
even behaviorists who are technically
embedded in the scientific world are
still pregnant,
practical emphasis because what they're
consistently doing with their clients is
breaking down whatever the problems are
that are causing the misery,
breaking them down into sub problems and
trying to figure out solutions that
improve their quality of life,
like practical,
implementable solutions that improve
their quality of life.
Not only now,
but as they propagate into the future.
And that is not a scientific issue.
It's a how to live issue.
So the entire history of the 20th
century,
in some sense,
political,
economic,
and psychological was a sequence of
attempts to answer the question when
your fundamental systems of ethics
collapse.
How is it that you should live
now?
Nisha said very clearly that there would
be two to the collapse of these systems
and one would be nihilism.
The belief that nothing at all,
which he also regarded as a form of
escape from responsibility.
So it's a logical consequence of the
breakdown of classical belief systems,
but it's also a a cop out and it's the
kind of cop out the Dostoevsky explored
very deeply in his small,
brilliant novel notes from underground
which describes a person who's basically
slipped an intelligent person and an
irresponsible person who's basically
slipped into a pit of meaninglessness
where he experienced his hatred and
resentment and the desire for revenge
and all of the sorts of things that
would afflict someone in the underworld
who's got nothing to hold them together.
And then of course you also talked about
the likelihood that people would turn to
totalitarian belief systems such as.
And he particularly discussed communism
as a replacement for religious belief.
I can give you a Canadian example of
that.
So I heard a Gallup pollster one time,
I was at a conference in Ottawa.
So the only time I've ever heard this,
and I think it's an amazing.
It's an amazing fact.
They were looking at the probability
that people would be separatist in
Quebec and if you are a lapsed Catholic,
the probability that you will be a
separate as was increased 10 times.
And the reason for that is,
you know,
Catholicism fell apart in Quebec in the
late 19 fifties.
It was one of the last places in the
Western world,
roughly speaking,
where the,
the feudal in some sense structures of
Catholicism had maintained themselves
right up to that point,
right up until the 19 fifties,
late 19 fifties.
And that collapsed precipitously low,
just like belief in Christianity had in
Russia,
you know,
in the late,
say 18 eighties.
And what happened in Quebec was,
well first of all,
the birth rate plummeted.
I mean,
I did genetic research in Quebec and in
the 19 fifties and before that it was
very typical to see families of nine to
13 children.
And of course now rebecca has the lowest
birth rate.
I believe in the Western world.
It's way below replacement.
Everybody bailed out of the church.
Nobody gets married.
And if you were a separate as if you
were a lapsed Catholic,
you are 10 times more likely to be a
separatist.
All that meant was that with Catholicism
fell apart,
you know,
people who still needed to have very
structured belief systems just turned to
nationalism as a natural alternative,
you know,
and that's part of what,
that's part of what accounted for the,
the rigidity and utopian,
uh,
the utopia and utopia nature of the
Quebec movement towards independence.
You know,
I remember talking to one of my
colleagues are very,
very intelligent person and uh,
you know,
I asked him because at that point they
were predicting that if Quebec
separated,
the Canadian dollar would fall to forty
cents,
forty five cents.
US something like that and be complete
economic catastrophe.
I said,
well,
you know,
the,
the predictions are that if Canada
separates and first of all or Quebec
separates and no one would know how to
do that as the Canadian economy will
collapse,
and of course that'll collapse the
Quebec economy too.
And he didn't deny that.
He said,
yeah,
but it would be worth it.
And I thought,
well,
there's just no way of having a
conversation and under those
circumstances,
because from my perspective,
total,
you know,
severe economic collapse is a good
reason not to do something,
but if you believe that the pope of
future potential is such that that's
justified,
then well,
there's no arguing with you.
It's just something that you decided.
And that's the end of that.
And when I lived in Quebec,
as I did for a long time,
I learned very quickly never have a
discussion about politics with anyone
who was a separatist because it was just
absolutely counterproductive.
You know,
they had axioms of belief that were
movable.
The future will be good enough so that
no matter what price we pay in the
present,
that will be justified.
It's like,
well,
that's not an idea,
right?
It's a statement of faith and you saw
exactly the same thing happening,
not with the same principles.
I'm not saying that,
but you saw the same thing happening
from a psychological perspective in
Russia when the Communists,
you know,
when the communists really started to
become active in the 19 twenties when
any matter of horror whatsoever was
fully justifiable because it was going
to bring about some future state that
was basically equivalent to paradise.
So anyways,
so and then you know,
Dostoevsky pursued the idea of nihilism
even farther because Dostoevsky was
certainly someone who is willing to go
to the ends of an argument and one of
the things he proclaimed was that if
there was no god than anything was
permitted and his basic hypothesis was
well as if there is no all ultimate
arbiter of values.
If there's no transcendent arbiter of
values,
then you're radically free.
Now the existentialists would say,
well,
you could use that radical freedom to
find meaning in your life,
but one of the things Dostoevsky
realized was that you could use that
radical freedom for anything that you
wanted.
And so in his book,
crime and punishment,
for example,
he explores the actions and beliefs of a
student named rascal in the cog and
rescheduled the call is a starving
student.
He's a law student and he doesn't have
enough to eat.
So of course he's his cognition is a
little bit on the adult side because
he's going through periods of starvation
and drunkenness,
so it's not like he's thinking that
clearly he wants to become a law student
so that it can help society and he finds
out that his sister is basically willing
to enter into a loveless marriage and
more or less prostituted herself so that
she can generate enough money to share
with her mother so that they can fund
his continuation through law school and
he thinks that wouldn't be a very good
deal.
At the same time,
he's indebted a pawn broker who everyone
hates,
who is an absolutely miserable person in
every possible way.
Dostoevsky sets up the situation like
that.
So the pawn broker has a nice,
if I remember correctly,
who she basically enslaved and
mistreated,
and she squirrels,
squirrels away,
all sorts of money,
but never does anything with it,
lives in absolute poverty and anyways,
he considers her the sort of person
without whom the world would be a better
place.
So having all of these things co
occurring in his imagination,
he decides that because there are no
ultimate arbiter of value,
that all morality is essentially
cowardice,
which is kind of the reverse of what
nature concluded.
See,
said most people were cowardly and
justified that with their morality,
but responding to calls took the other
idea,
which is,
well,
why do I have to obey any rules at all?
If there's no ultimate source for any of
these rules?
It's just convention and cowardice.
And,
and if I have enough strength,
then I can leave outside of that
framework and I can do whatever I want.
So he decides to kill the,
the pawnbroker,
which he does and quite successfully.
And not only that,
he gets away with it and that's about
the first third of crime and punishment.
And the rest of the book is the
discussion of the manner in which he
comes unglued as a consequence of having
performed this act.
And it's,
it's brilliant.
It's absolutely brilliant study of the
way that a value system holds you
together even in ways that you don't
know.
And then if you step outside of that
and,
and violate your relationship to it in
some really intense way,
then there's going to be catastrophic
psychological consequences that will
echo through your whole being.
You know,
we know that this is more than theory
because many people,
soldiers in particular who develop
posttraumatic stress disorder,
develop posttraumatic stress disorder
when they observe themselves doing
something that they regard as
tremendously cruel or vicious or
immoral.
You know,
when they're in the situation where,
you know,
uh,
acting that acting in that manner is
highly probable.
It's a war situation usually very
intense.
And you know,
they don't have a lot of time to make
decisions.
And God only knows what the specifics
are of the particular event.
But many,
many people come to be so shattered by
observing themselves do things they
can't believe that a human being would
be capable of doing that they never
recovered,
and it's partly because you know they
violate their,
their ethical,
the ethical structure that holds them
together,
holds older ideas and their plans and
their perceptions and their interactions
with other people.
That's a unified field in some sense,
and if you violate it and it fragments,
then you're left absolutely fragmented.
Then that's,
that's not,
that's not even a psychological
observation.
It's a psychophysiological observation.
You can stress yourself so badly,
raise your stress level so high that
your brain starts to become damaged by
the stress hormones and you know,
so it's.
It's not just a psychological state,
it's,
it's damaged to the core of your being
in some sense.
Now the collapse of these belief systems
and their destabilization was well
thought through by these thinkers by the
end of the 19th century.
And then we have the technological
transformations and the and the
sociological and political
transformations of the early part of the
20th century.
That leaves everyone in a state of
confusion in some sense,
like in Germany in the 19 twenties,
of course,
the Germans had gone through this
terrible period of trench warfare,
so they're all there.
Men were brutalized.
Some of them had been on the front for
months and that was in the trenches and
then you know,
their political system had collapsed and
they'd put a week,
weekly rooted democracy in place and
then the economic system collapsed in
Germany,
went through a period of hyperinflation.
So that money,
the value of their money basically
dropped to zero.
And so that meant that if he were 65
years old and had saved up your whole
life to have enough money to retire and
we're a good citizen,
you know,
and,
and prudent and careful.
Every single thing you ever own
disappeared.
And so at the same time,
you know,
the communist revolution had taken place
in Soviet Russia and there was great
concern within Germany that the same
thing was likely to happen there.
And certainly the,
the communists were always pushing for
that because they had the common term
which is the international communist
movement,
which was devoted towards destabilizing,
you know,
non communist governments and,
and producing the preconditions for the
revolution.
So it wasn't,
wasn't like it was just paranoia was a
real threat and it was out of all that
mess that came,
the emergence of the fascists and the
Nazis.
And it's not that,
you know,
it's,
it's not that surprising because chaos
breeds the desire for order.
And so that was what,
that was one direction that people could
go,
you know,
instead of following an abstract
Messiah,
let's say this sort of idea that was
embedded in classical Christianity,
they realized the new Messiah not was
Hitler.
And that certainly didn't seem to be any
improvement because Hitler was really a
messiah,
destruction and fire.
And you know,
the World War Two killed about $120
million people.
And of course it left Germany in
absolute ruins.
And Hitler killed himself in his bunker
underneath Berlin while it was burning.
And the Russians were advancing into
the,
you know,
into Germany.
And they were not happy.
You didn't want to be a German national.
Well,
the Soviets were advancing towards you
after your,
after your country to invaded.
There's pushed them back halfway across
the Soviet Union,
you know,
and produced a tremendous amount of
damage and,
and distress.
It was an awful situation,
you know,
and uh,
the Messiah is that the,
that the Russians turned to Lenin and
Stalin were barbaric and brutal beyond
comprehension.
You know,
and it's,
it's a strange thing,
you know,
we're not very well educated in what
happened in this,
in the Soviet Union in the 20th century.
We know far more about what happened in
Germany say with the Holocaust and you
know,
it's very important that people should
know about that.
But there were tens of millions of
people brutally destroyed in the Soviet
Union.
And you know,
partly because they were murdered by
people who were,
at least in principle,
motivated by left wing Utopian visions.
We seem to.
Our education system seems to regard
that as somehow more forgivable,
which it certainly isn't.
So you know,
the whole,
the whole generate secular alternatives
to religious belief issue didn't seem to
work out very well.
And then the nihilism alternative.
Well that has its own problems.
One problem is the sort of Dostoevsky
talked about,
you know,
when you see the kids who go up and
shoot,
shoot up high schools and exploded in
rage,
you know,
they're often people who feel that they
have no meaning in their life,
that life itself is contemptible and
that suffering is too extreme and that
they're,
they bear the brunt of unfair reality
and you know,
they develop unbelievably dark and,
and destructive theories of,
of revenge and mayhem over sometimes
over the period of years.
And then they go up in the world and lay
those things out and it's not like
they're thinking is irrational know it's
coherent.
It's just predicated on principles that
you might not agree with such as the
principle that everyone that I don't
like deserves to die.
But you know,
in the absence of a really formal way of
demonstrating that such thoughts are not
only immoral but wrong.
You know,
in some absolute sense.
It's very difficult to come up with ways
of defending ourselves against those two
extremes,
the extremes of destructive vitalism and
the extremes of ideological possession.
Now,
nature started to work out some some
solutions to this and I just started to
touch on those at the end of the last
lecture,
you know,
Dostoevsky solution was a return to
Christianity fundamentally,
and it's revivification and that was the
same tack that Alexander Soldier Nixon
attempted to lay out and also tolstoy in
Russia.
You know,
and I'll talk to you about that a little
bit more in the next lecture,
dusty or niches idea was that people
would have to.
He said,
you know,
when his quote about the death of God,
that people would have to become light,
God's just to be able to tolerate the
consequences of this dismemberment,
of the previous civilization.
And he believed,
well,
his thinking on this,
I would say is somewhat fragmentary.
I mean,
nature was a great critic of
Christianity,
institutionalized Christianity and a
great diagnostician.
He could say what was rotten at the core
of western civilization will say modern
civilization,
but when it came to actually describing
what to do about it,
well,
he didn't live that long.
You know,
he died a fairly young man.
There's actually a video of meets you in
the mental hospital online.
I just found it the other night.
I have no idea that he was ever captured
on video,
but there's video from a movie from a
1899 showing him in the mental hospital
where he ended up in his early forties.
So he talked about the development of
the,
of the being.
He called the overmanned,
which is often translated as superman
and his idea was that people would have
to take onto themselves the the burden
of creating new systems of meaning and
new morality's that were suited to them
that they would have to create new
values.
Now,
young took niches,
diagnosis very,
very seriously and you can.
You can certainly say that young was as
much influenced by niche as he was by
Freud.
And I would say in some ways he was
influenced more because one of the
things that yoga was trying to do was to
identify where the last values had gone.
So the Nietzschean idea is that it's
possible for human beings to create
their own values.
Now there's a problem with that.
There's a variety of problems with that.
And one is that it's,
it doesn't seem exactly true in that,
you know,
and,
and a lot of the existentialists who
followed each other,
like John Paul Sartre,
for example,
believed in the radical freedom of human
beings that we were,
we were doomed to be free in a sense.
And that was absolutely necessary for us
to conjure up our own meanings and
values because fundamentally we faced
the void and you know,
life was nasty,
brutish and short to use hobbs terms.
And that we had to be able to confront
that and live despite it.
And well,
there's a variety of problems with that
solution.
The first one is,
well,
if you come up with your system of
values,
there's no reason.
And I come up with mine,
there's no reason to assume that they're
going to be sufficiently integratable so
that we don't have to fight each other
to the death.
That's a big problem.
So you know,
you'd have every single person with
their own system of beliefs.
Well,
fine extent.
How do you know that?
In a sense that's a structured kind of
philosophical anarchy.
Well,
okay,
maybe that's good if you have to live
alone on an island,
but if you're stuck with all these other
people,
then that becomes a very difficult thing
to.
And I think it's partly for that reason
that Sartre famously said,
hell is other people,
you know,
because he thought of the other in some
sense that which was not him as an
oppressive forest that stopped him from
manifesting his destiny in the way that
would have been best for him.
Well,
you know,
hell might be other people,
but that doesn't mean that,
first of all,
that's a very one sided way of looking
at things because of course,
how it is other people hell is you too.
When you know hell is nature.
There's lots of places you could find
hail,
but by the same token,
you know,
the most meaningful elements of people's
lives are often their social
relationships and you can't lay
everything at the door of pathological
society,
you know,
and we shouldn't forget as well that
Sartre didn't,
uh,
what come up with any reasonable
critique of the communists until the
late 19 sixties,
but,
you know,
but that was a little late.
People with any sense like George Orwell
had figured out that the whole Soviet
experiment had become radically
murderous by the early 19 forties.
And so starcher proposed radical freedom
as a,
as the existential response to the
unveiling of no meaning.
But when it came right down to it,
he couldn't resist identification with a
totalitarian structure.
So I don't see any reason why we should
really pay any attention to what he had
to say.
So now there's another problem with the
idea that people should create their own
values.
And that is the,
it's not so simple,
you know,
and the problem seems to be is that you
don't obey yourself very well.
You know,
you can say,
well,
here's my code.
I'm going to live by it,
so we let's do that simply to begin
with.
You say,
well,
I'm going to study very hard and do well
at my classes just for the sake of
argument,
you know,
but you don't know.
You procrastinate and you have a paper
you're supposed to read and you know
you're supposed to read it and you need
to read it for reasons that are even
hypothetically important to you,
but there's no damn way you can get
yourself to sit down and read it.
Your attention wanders and you go to do
three or four stupid things and you feel
terrible about it.
Like you feel like you're betraying
yourself and maybe this is a continual
pattern in your life,
but one of the things you find out is
that you don't get to create your own
damn values because for some reason
you're not in charge of yourself.
And of course that's where the
psychoanalytic ideas start to come from.
You know,
Freud notices.
This is in the aftermath of nature,
that you're not the master of your own
psyche.
You know that there's,
there's many sub use inside of you and
they don't all want the same thing and
so the idea that you can generate your
own meaning is very,
it's,
it's insufficiently developed idea
because there's a lot of meaning making
generators residing within you and not
only do they not all point in the same
direction,
which is a huge problem,
but they don't even necessarily.
They don't necessarily lay themselves
out in some integrated fashion across
time and they don't necessarily operate
together in a way that's going to enable
you to find your place with other people
and in society.
So you know,
make your own meaning well,
which part of you,
you know,
you're not a unified thing,
so that's a big problem.
And then all these other problems just
remain unaddressed completely.
Well,
one answer to that,
and this is the answer that the more
radical existentialists took as well.
Society has to be reconfigured,
but you know,
we kind of know where that leads to when
people are doing radical societal
reconfiguration,
at least as far as we've been able to
tell most of the time.
That's an absolute murderous
catastrophe,
so you know,
it's reasonable.
It seems reasonable to me to presume
that that those experiments have already
been run.
All right,
so now you like Dostoevsky was very
interested in returning to sources of
meaning from which he believed that our
original religious ideas had emerged.
And this is partly his notion of the
collective unconscious.
So you know,
part of the radical critique of
religious systems is predicated on the
idea that there's something like
conscious beliefs are articulated
beliefs that you could lay out in a
credo,
but,
but that's not right.
It doesn't seem to be correct at all.
And Nietzsche actually knew this.
He knew that a lot of our social
institutions had emerged from the bottom
up and it only become articulated after
they'd been embodied and danced out.
Essentially,
you know,
you are a tribal group learns how to
organize itself over thousands and
thousands of years of trial and error
and pushing against each other and so
forth.
And they come into that tribal grouping
with a biological substrate and there
are sociological and political
interactions are constrained by all of
those things.
And then maybe they come up with a
description of that over time,
the self description and an articulated
representation.
And that's the religious system.
It's not that the religious system is
thought up first as a system of
metaphysical presuppositions,
images and dreams,
then turn it into rules then imposed on
the population who then obeys it.
And generally speaking,
when people criticized,
um,
formal religion,
they criticized it,
assuming that that's how it had
developed,
you know,
and that's kind of a Marxist idea,
for example,
that religion is the opiate of the
masses and that,
you know,
the religious structures were laid out
so that a small elite could control the
population.
Now,
you know,
in virtually every domain,
a small elite emerges that dominates the
population.
I don't care what domain you look at.
So mark's is accurate in that way,
in that,
you know,
there's always a power imbalance between
elite minority and majority.
But to say that that's the cause of all
the systems that people interact within
is wild.
It's,
it's,
I'm sophisticated beyond belief.
What it does is it takes phenomena.
There are complex beyond comprehension
and reduce them to one thing.
It's not helpful like,
you know,
here's an example.
Um,
if you,
if you sampled popular songs on the,
on Youtube,
let's say you made a graph of how
popular songs were,
what you find is that about 10 songs at
any given time are played,
half of all the songs played at any
given time are going to be one of 10
songs.
Well,
and then what the other thing you'd find
is that half of all songs played are
played by one or more of 10 musicians.
And that's true,
no matter,
you know,
if you look all the way from the 19,
32 now,
if you look at popular music,
you see the same thing.
Almost everything that almost everyone
listens to is created by very few
people.
And then there's millions of musicians,
but you've never heard of most of them.
And you'll never hear a song.
For most,
it's a small minority.
And what you see as in any field of
creative production,
this happens.
A small elite emerges and dominates the
entire landscape.
Now,
you know,
it's kind of,
it would be kind of ridiculous to assume
that the 10 most popular singers and
musicians that are currently operative
word,
those who gave rise to the system that
allowed them to thrive.
I mean obviously that's a dopey idea and
it's,
it's no more an intelligent idea.
When you look at any other domain where
there's tremendous variation and the
emergence of an elite,
it's a very common phenomenon.
It happens,
as I said,
it happens anywhere.
There's creative production,
so that's why one percent of the people,
you know,
roughly half,
50 percent of the money,
it's no different in,
in other creative domains.
Now we'll talk later in the course about
why that happens,
but to think it's because those people
set up the system so that they could
thrive this.
Well.
There's an element of that obviously
because once you're rich,
you're going to prefer political
policies that helped you stay rich.
But that doesn't mean that you set up
the whole damn system that made you rich
to begin with.
Plus,
it's not the same people over any
reasonable span of time.
So the one percent of people who have
most of the money,
it's always one percent,
but it's not the same people each in
individuals tend to hold onto money for
very short periods of time and big
companies don't last very long.
You know,
they,
they last on average about 30,
35,
40 years and that's it.
Then they disappear.
So what does,
because you know,
the economic landscape is just churning
like Mac.
It's very difficult for a company to,
you know,
there's not that many big steam coach
companies anymore,
you know,
and,
and nobody makes zepplins and nobody
makes typewriters and you know what I
mean is things move quick and just
because you dominated the landscape at
one particular moment doesn't mean
you're going to be able to do it that
the next.
So,
all right,
so the create your own meaning thing is
a rough one.
And then there's another problem too,
which is what makes you think you have
enough time.
You know,
lots of times people come to me and they
have relationship problems and part of
the problem is is that they've set their
relationships up outside of social norms
and they do that,
you know,
so they'll say something to me,
something like,
well,
we're not going to get married because
marriage is just a piece of paper,
which is really a stupid thing to say
like it's an incredibly stupid thing to
say,
but underneath that there's this idea
that they want to remain free of social
constraints so that they can negotiate
their own way.
Like if you're giving them credit for
wanting freedom instead of just escaping
responsibility.
But the problem with that is it's like,
okay,
good luck.
Try it.
I don't know why you would assume that
you have enough time in the 30 or 40
years that you're going to be pursuing
relationships to actually figure out how
they should run.
You don't have a hope of that and it's
worse too because very,
very few people can negotiate,
you know,
because here's the way it works.
You either adhere to the social order or
you stand outside as soon as you stand
outside of it,
you're in a chaotic place because
there's no guidelines and then you
either live chaotically because there's
no guidelines or you start to formulate
order.
But to do that you have to know what you
want and you have to know how to express
it and then you have to figure out what
your partner wants and help them express
it.
And then you have to negotiate a
solution.
Well,
I would say one in 20 people know how to
negotiate.
It's really,
really difficult.
If you mean just think of the steps.
First of all,
you have to know what you want and then
you have to admit it to yourself.
Well,
yeah,
right.
Like you,
you're not even going to get to the
first one.
In all likelihood.
What do you want?
A lot of what you want can't be
articulated even,
you know,
I'll give you an example.
So there's a great study done awhile
back on the prediction of mayor of,
of a relationship longevity.
Okay.
So here was the question,
um,
how many negative interactions do you
have to have per set of positive?
Sorry?
How many positive interactions per
negative interaction do you have to have
with your partner in order for the
relationship to remain stable?
Okay,
so let's say you have one negative
interaction to every one positive
interaction.
Okay.
Or maybe have 10 negatives to every
positive.
Then you could imagine a different
situation where you have 100 positive to
one negative spanning the whole
potential.
Continue and you use that to predict
relationship satisfaction and longevity.
While you might think,
well God obviously 100 positive to one
negative is where is the preferable
ratio?
And so it's those people who,
you know,
their relationship is nothing but
constant compliments and bliss.
They're the ones who last.
It's not true.
What you see is that there's a,
there's a,
an optimal,
an optimal ratio domain.
If it falls below five to one positive
to negative,
then your relationship falls apart.
It's too negative.
And it's partly because people feel
negative emotion more than they feel
positive emotions because you can be
hurt more than you can be.
Pleased.
And so one that's only five to one is to
punishing and people won't,
won't stay in.
But if you get above 11 to one,
it gets not punishing enough.
And you think,
well,
what does that mean exactly?
Well,
what do you want in a relationship?
you think bliss.
It's like that isn't what you want.
As it turns out,
it's more like you want someone to
contend with,
you know,
you don't want to push over.
You don't want everything to be easy,
you know,
and this is the sort of the sort of
phenomena that kierkegaard was talking
about when he talked about deciding to
make things more difficult for people
because that's what they need.
You know,
you know this perfectly well because if
you go out with someone and they worship
you and they don't on your every word
and there's nothing but positive
feedback coming from them,
you lose respect for them almost an
instantly.
And you go wander off and find someone
who's more interesting.
And part of the reason for that I think
is that you want the person that you're
with to challenge you so that not only
do you do reasonably well data gate day
together,
you know,
so you can coexist in the same space
with a reasonable amount of pace,
but you also want there to be enough
tension in the relationship so that
you're both involved in a process of
mutual transformation while try
specifying that in an articulated way,
you know,
good luck,
and it also explains strange things
about people like the fact that they'll
stay in pretty negative relationships.
Like what the hell are you doing there?
If you had articulated it two years ago
and you said,
well,
I want to be with someone,
I'm miserable with half the time,
of course you're never going to say
that,
but it could easily be that that's what
you're after.
So.
Well,
so alright,
now heidegger is another philosopher who
was attempting in some sense to solve
the problems that were laid out by
Nietzsche and Dostoevsky.
And the way that heidegger heidegger
began to resolve them was by a radically
new lookout philosophy itself,
and he was,
he was,
he was one of the prime phenomenologists
and I told you a while back that the
phenomenologists decided to reconstitute
western philosophy.
So that was focusing on being instead of
knowledge.
And so the hardest thing to grasp about
the phenomenologists is what exactly
they meant by being an.
So I'll give you a,
I'll give you a overview of that.
So that's where the term Dad's side
comes from and that's a German term and
it means being there.
And so right now you're encapsulated in
a data site and the design is the
totality of your experience and that
experience would be an experience of the
extended world,
the natural world,
and then the social world.
And then inside that the world of your
subjective experience and that
constitutes being.
And the phenomenologists make the case.
They're not playing this subject object
gate and they're standing outside of the
division between subject and object.
That's part of the scientific world
view.
So it's a real paradigm shift in that
you can't use the rules from the old way
of looking at things inside the new way
of looking at things.
You have to start with new
presupposition.
So we might say,
well,
one of the things that you're going to
do if you look at things
phenomenologically,
is to assume that everything that you
experienced is real.
So,
so then we would say that there's no
attempt in that phenomenal logical world
to reduce pain to something material.
Pain stands as stands itself as a
phenomena,
so does anxiety,
so does joy.
All the things that the scientists of
consciousness called Kaleo,
which are viewed by them as qualities of
the objective world,
aren't viewed that way by the
phenomenologists.
They just say those are primary elements
of being.
So it's a very interesting way of
looking at things because it kind of
allows you to reclaim the validity of
your own experience.
You can no longer say,
well,
that's only subjective and that doesn't
mean that everything you played
subjectively is true objectively or for
other people.
What it does mean is that everything
that you experience subjectively is
real.
Now,
that doesn't mean you.
You have to not think about it or take
it apart or categorize it properly.
You still have to do all of those
things,
but you're.
You're put into a place where there is
no need to deny the reality of your own
experience or to subordinate it to
something else.
So for example,
if I'm doing dream analysis with
someone,
which I do often,
if people dream,
because dreams as you pointed out,
are there they are.
They're manifestations of being.
You don't come up with them.
They appear to you.
They sort of appear out of nowhere in
some sense.
They manifest themselves.
They do.
It strangely began and I think the
reason for that is that they contain
unarticulated thought,
but if you can get a handle on them and
assess them,
then sometimes they can tell you things
that there's no other way you can figure
out.
And what's really cool about them is
that they're.
They have the same impersonality as
phenomena in the,
like the broader world of experience.
Have you know you don't ever think about
the truth of a chair,
it's just there and dreams are like
that.
They're just there and if you can
untangle what they have to what they
indicate,
then you can get a take on your own
experience that's not
altered by any of your local subjective
wishes and desires.
I hate to use the word subjective in
this sort of context.
So phenomenology is the study of being
now,
now and in being.
There are variety of aspects and so one
aspect,
I never remember the names of these,
but I'll get it here right away.
Oh yes.
Heidegger broke the world of experience
being into three basic categories.
There was the [inaudible],
which I think is basically the world
beyond culture and the individual.
There's the midwest and that's the world
that we share with everyone else.
So that's roughly the social world and
the social structures.
And then there's the eigenvalue which is
that domain of experience that's unique
to you that other people can't partake
in.
So those are the elements of being as
far as the phenomenologists were
concerned and in those domains of being
different experiences manifest
themselves.
We talked about some of the ones that
would be manifestations of the
I can belt.
Scientists would call those things
emotional or motivational states.
Normally people think of them as
feelings,
I would say I feel that's I feel such
and such,
and those are experiences that,
that manifest themselves to you or that
you have,
depending on how you look at it that are
indicative of the manner in which you
should act in relationship to being.
Now,
one of,
part of the reason that this is relevant
to psychotherapy in particular was
because the,
the,
uh,
the phenomenologists were very
interested in the manifestation of
meaning.
So you could say,
well,
nihilism is the absence of meaning and
totalitarianism is the fixed edness of
meaning,
right?
If you're a totalitarian,
what you do is say all exist in
relationship to this structure.
It's almost as if from the
phenomenologists would say you're trying
to reduce the,
the weld,
which is the natural world,
the Mip dwelled,
which is the social world.
And the Eigen belt,
which is your own world,
you're trying to reduce all of that to
the well so that everything falls under
an explanation that's granted to you by
some higher authority.
And then of course the nihilists art are
having none of that.
They see,
they,
they use their eigen felt,
I would say their own world to
invalidate meaning in any domain.
Now the phenomenologists would say,
well,
it's a mistake to use your rationality
to undermine the,
the sense,
the manifestation of meaning.
And I can give you an example of that.
So let's say you're a good nihilist and
you think that maybe you're going to go
do something difficult,
like put yourself through university and
then you think in a relatively depressed
state of mind,
maybe you encountered some obstacles of
one form or another,
and you think,
oh,
to hell with this.
Who's,
what difference does it make anyways?
Who cares if I go and get my degree?
You know,
none of this knowledge is particularly
relevant or meaningful,
and who the hell is going to know the
difference in a million years?
And so you think,
well,
that's a perfectly rational,
um,
dismissal because who is going to know
in a million years or let's say,
well,
even if you could make a case that
someone might know there might be some
effects left of you in a million years,
then we'll just multiply it by 100,000
and go to a trillion years.
So here you are,
you're this little tiny speck on a
slightly bigger speck in the middle of a
galaxy that has god only knows how many
billion stars.
And then there's a billion of those
galaxies.
Although there's way more than that and
they're spread across this tremendous
expanse of time.
And in the face of all that,
who cares what you do?
Well,
what a phenomenologist would say is,
okay,
let's look at how meaning manifests
itself when you alter your own
private world in a variety of manners.
So let's say you're trying to do
something.
Maybe you're working in a,
maybe you're working as a volunteer in a
hospital helping sick kids.
You know,
you're reading to them so that they're
distracted from their pain.
And you say,
well,
when their trillion years,
who's going to know the difference?
And so you think,
well,
it's meaningless to do this.
The phenomenologists would say if the
frame of reference that you're using,
like if you're.
If you're imposing,
if you're transforming the way you're
being manifests itself so that it
becomes meaningless and observed,
then you should try experiencing it in a
different manner.
So it's d,
c,
because a rationalist in some sense the
phenomenology say a rationalist can't
deal with the argument.
What difference is it going to make an a
trillion years and here you are,
a little dust speck among all these
other despots.
It's ultimately meaningless.
A phenomenologist would say maximize the
meaning.
That's the.
That's the marker of truth and it's a.
it's a completely different way of
thinking about it.
So he would say,
for example,
that if you're going to a hospital and
you're reading to sick children,
that the frame of reference that you
should use,
the way that you allow that experience
to manifest itself should be such that
the experience manifests itself so that
it's as meaningful as possible rather
than is meaning less.
The idea being that just because you can
twist your own experience so that
certain elements of your being become
meaningless does not mean that that's
right.
The fact that it becomes meaningless
actually means that it's wrong because
you think you see it all depends on what
you allow to be primary,
and this is the phenomenologists point.
If you allow your strict rationality to
be primary than if it can attack
something and destroy it,
then that thing is worthy of being
attacked and destroyed.
But if you flip it around and you say,
well,
what you should be doing is allowing is
interacting with your experience or
allowing your experience to manifest
itself in a manner that situates you
most meaningfully in the here and now.
Whatever framework you're using to do
that,
that works is right.
That's a completely different way of
looking at things and it's a real.
It's a real escape from the pathology of
rationalism.
No,
because it isn't obvious that what you
think should take priority.
Now the phenomenologists would go
farther than that.
They would say that,
and this is something,
so here's a way of thinking about it.
So bins,
Wanger Sad.
What we perceive our first and foremost
bins.
Wanger was a psychiatrist who is very
much influenced in sweating your boss,
where the people going to talk about
mostly were very much influenced by
Heidegger area and ideas.
I say what we perceive our first and
foremost,
not impressions of taste,
smell or touch.
Not even things or objects,
but meanings.
Okay,
so the idea for the phenomenologists is
that what being is made out of is
meaning.
It isn't that the objective world is
made out of things.
It's that being is made out of meaning.
Now,
some of those meetings can be positive
and some of them can be negative and
some of them can be neutral,
but the constituent elements of being
the fundamental constituent element of
being his meaning,
and then there is an argument between
been swagger in Boston about how that
meaning manifest itself,
so been swaying or would say that you
endow meaning on the world,
so that's kind of a Nietzschean idea
that you create your own values so that
you have within you something he called
an a priori ontological structure,
so world designed or a matrix of meaning
that determines how the world manifests
itself to you.
Now the easiest way to think about that
is that you know you're thrown into a
particular time and place.
That's another existentialist idea,
and that's part of the absurdity of your
life,
is that you're here.
Now in this particular context and
situation,
it's something you have to contend with
and that's true for everyone.
They're arbitrary preconditions to
everyone's being and one of those
arbitrary preconditions is the structure
through which you look at the world and
that structure enables some things to be
highlighted in some things to be
ignored,
and so the way that meaning manifests
itself is a reflection of this,
a priori ontological structure,
the mode of being so there can't be
being which is say your experience for
the sake of our argument,
without the structure that consists of
you,
that that you consist up and so that's a
given and it's.
It's the action of that structure that
determines the meaning of things.
Now boss would say exactly the opposite.
He would say that's the wrong way of
looking at it.
You should look at the totality of your
existence,
which is partly the broad natural world,
the cultural world,
and your own world,
and you should note that meaning arises
in different places of its own accord.
You can't.
You can't reduce it to the action,
say of this ontological,
a priority ontological structure,
and so one example would be,
well,
what about the meaning of things you
don't understand?
Well,
it's hard to understand how the meaning
of things you don't understand can be
attributed to what you understand.
The meaning seems to be there to begin
with.
So here's an example.
Your,
your.
You have a relationship with someone and
you discover that they have an affair.
Well,
the discovery of the affair is going to
be something that's meaningful.
Now you don't know what the meaning is.
You're going to interpret it to begin
with likely very negatively,
except to the degree that part of you
would like to escape out of the
relationship,
right?
Because sometimes if you're betrayed,
you're happy about it because it's time
for that to be overweight,
but in any case,
there are things that you can encounter
that you don't understand,
that are meaningful in and of
themselves.
So I think that you actually can't
separate your structure from the
structure of everything.
They're always interacting and meaning
emerges out of the interplay of those.
So here's another way of thinking about
it.
You're reading a book.
The book is meaningful.
Where is the meaning?
Is it in your head?
Is it in the book?
While it's very difficult to say,
right,
because obviously there's a subjective
element to it.
There's an element that's unique to you,
but just as obviously that meaning
wouldn't manifest itself if it wasn't
for the book and of course the book
wouldn't be meaningful if you end the
book weren't embedded in this complex
structure and so the meaning is an
emergent property.
The meeting is an emergent property of
the interplay of all of the elements of
being.
That's a very interesting way of looking
at things.
So you have all these elements of PA and
their dance produces meaning of one form
or another.
Now you might say if you were a
phenomenologist that some of that
meaning is going to be life sustaining
and some of it is going to be life
destroying and the phenomenologists
would say from a clinical perspective
that your,
if your.
If you are,
if you exist in a system of meaning,
revelations that are life destroying,
that you should turn your attention away
from them towards meetings that are life
affirming.
And you know,
one of the things that's quite
interesting about the phenomenal logical
perspective is that you can experiment
with it quite easily.
So I could say to you,
for example,
a couple of phenomenological
experiments,
one would be for the next two weeks,
you want to detach yourself in some
sense so that you're a curious observer
of your being.
You're not necessarily trying to direct
it,
you know you're just trying to let it
unfold.
And then what you might want to watch
for is when the meaning that manifests
itself as,
as things flow around you is clearly
meaning of the life affirming type.
Now you'll see that,
you know,
it depends on how well situated you are
in some sense because if you're,
if you're surrounded by,
if your experiential field is primarily
negative,
these are going to be relatively rare
events,
but they will still not be nonexistent.
They might only happen for a few seconds
or a few minutes every day or every few
days.
But so say,
okay,
you notice that all of a sudden you're
in a place where things are the way you
would like them to be.
So you could say you're in a place where
being is manifesting itself as
acceptable.
Okay,
so that's a place where nihilism is not
appropriate.
It doesn't apply because of the quality
of the experience is such that it's life
affirming.
You have to notice that it's something
that happens and then you might ask
yourself,
well,
okay,
what are the preconditions that enabled
that?
What are the preconditions that enabled
all of the different sub elements of
being to work harmoniously together at
that time in place so that that was the
meaning that emerged and then the next
question might be how would it be
possible for me to allow that to happen
more frequently?
And so you can tilt yourself towards
life affirming meetings in a way from,
from say meanings that are associated
with disparate nihilism,
but you do that partly.
It's almost like you're navigating in a
boat.
In fact,
I think you are.
I think you're navigating to find the
line between order and chaos because
that's where the meaning is.
That's exactly where the meaning is.
And you can feel it like it's a place
and that's the other thing.
The phenomenologists are trying to get
across these things are real.
They're not secondary manifestations of
some deeper reality.
They are reality itself.
I also think,
and we'll talk about this more when we
get to the neuropsychological portion of
the course,
that your brain is actually set up first
and foremost to detect meaning.
You detect meaning before you detect
objects and it's partly because you.
You have to detect meetings so that you
know what to do when something happens
very rapidly and there are times when
you have to figure out what to do before
you have enough time to even see what's
there.
You just don't have the time.
So you know,
part of the question is,
well,
what exactly do you mean by meaning?
You know,
I think meaning is significance for
behavior or significance for this
structure that governs behavior,
but those are very,
very basic fundamental perceptions
there.
They're not.
You see the object and then you derive
the meaning.
It's exactly the opposite.
Many cases you perceive the meaning and
derive the object and there's plenty of
neurophysiological evidence for that.
For example,
you have lots of,
you know your retina is a pattern
detector and the retinal information is
transmitted to your brain alone,
the optic nerve,
branches,
and it goes lots of places in your body.
Some of it maps right onto your spinal
cord so that your eyes can make your
body move.
Some of it maps onto your Amygdala so
that what you perceive are the meanings
of facial expressions without even
perceiving the face.
So you can have people who have
blindsight,
a damaged visual cortex.
You can show them angry faces,
which they say they can't see,
but they'll respond to them electro
physiologically it as if they're being
exposed to something negative and it's
because of the retinal pattern is
manifesting itself right onto the
system.
That maps one form of meaning so you can
clearly have meaning without,
without object perception.
And so the idea that you derive the
meaning from the object.
You see the thing and then you attribute
meaning to the thing.
That's.
That's right.
At some levels of analysis,
but it's wrong and many other levels of
analysis.
And so the other thing I think that you
can try that's phenomenologically
informed.
This is quite an interesting trick.
It can really.
It's really hard on you.
Those be careful if you try this.
So one,
another thing you could try for two
weeks is to watch what you say.
You've got to detach yourself.
Again,
you have to remove the belief that your
thoughts and you are the same thing.
And then you have to watch mostly what
you say and then you have to see.
And this is something that Rogers would
also be an advocate.
You have to see if what you say it makes
you feel what you have to see if what
you say improves the quality of your
being or makes it worse.
And you know,
if you start believing in what you say
and watch what the consequences are
instead,
how it manifests itself in terms of a
transformation of being.
Then you can also learn how to only say
things that improve the quality of
being.
Well,
that's a good thing if you can manage
it,
but,
but it's,
it's,
it's terrifying in some sense because
one of the things that you'll find is
that hardly anything that you say does
that most of it's neutral,
but a fair bit of it has exactly the
opposite consequences.
It makes things worse.
So I think I mentioned that the word
phenomena,
that's where the phenomenology,
the term phenomenology comes from.
Obviously the term phenomena means is
from the Greek word famous thigh and
famous diet means to shine forth.
And so the phenomenologies
phenomenologists argument is that like
being is made up of meanings that shine
forth for you and that those different
meanings attract you there.
They're like,
they're like guide posts that you can
follow.
So you know,
one of the,
I've noticed this for example in
relationship to reading,
so I'll be reading a complex tax and
some passage will really strike me.
So it manifests itself as meaningful.
Why is that?
Well,
you know,
one of the phenomenologists which would
be being been swagger,
we'd say,
well,
it's because of the way that I'm
structured,
but boss would say,
well,
no,
it's a dance that's occurring within the
structure of everything and the
consequence of that is the manifestation
manifestation of this meaning.
Well,
what I've found is that I can follow
threads of meaning through books.
You know that it's something that's
guiding me,
that sense of meaning.
And often if I find something within a
book that's meaningful,
then I'll read the other things that
that person wrote and I'll see that some
of the people that they read have
meaningful things to say and then I can
branch out that network.
And it's.
It's following a pathway that's laid out
for you in some sense that's laid out
for you in the world.
And you know,
the phenomenal logical idea is that if
you follow that pathway,
then what happens is being becomes more
and more integrated around you.
And those experiences of,
of intrinsic meaning start to multiply
and increase in intensity.
And you know,
if you're able to do that over a long
period of time,
then you can get more and more of the
totality of your being,
revealing the kinds of meanings that
stop you from being either nihilistic or
totalitarian.
And so,
well,
that's the basic.
That's the fundamental theory of
phenomenal logical psychotherapy.
You know,
we might first say,
well,
you know,
you're depressed and anxious and your
life isn't going very well.
What keeps you afloat?
It's a,
it's something to observe.
And then we might say,
well,
are there ways that we can expand that
small area that's keeping you afloat so
that it starts to occupied more and more
of your experience and push back the
parts that are either neutral or
negative and you know,
it's,
uh,
it's in large part a consequence of
attention and,
and willingness to first of all,
treat things as if they're meaning is
real.
And then second to allow that reality to
transform the way that you experience
things in the future.
See you Thursday.